so i don't want to brag but i'm going to
i think i might be the only person
that's unboxing
what's inside of here in front of an
xbox fridge
just just saying
don't ask questions i will do
this how i want
so if i were the rock how would i what
would i
how would i would i just what would the
rock do
do you think he would just be like he
would just look at it and it would unbox
itself
i don't think i have that ability
do you think i'm gonna need a chainsaw
for this serious question tyler shanky's
had no i don't
know if i agree with that
then how else will i open it without a
chainsaw there's no unboxing
instructions
oh okay so i lift the top off so that's
really all you had to do
i didn't even try to do this and it just
freaking opened
okay believe achieve repeat
so is packed with a healthy energy boost
vitamins and electrolytes that will set
you up with the mental power needed to
start your daily grind
whether you're streaming competing or
just playing for fun you'll get the
boost you need
with none of the crash best of all it
tastes incredible if dwayne says it does
i believe it thank you dwayne this is
exciting
also thank you xbox because there's
anything that you guys know that i like
it's xbox and my xbox fridge
do you think that i can put my mini
fridge inside the big fridge
well of course we're gonna do it you
guys don't even know what this is i
already know because my sister unboxed
it before me
it's an xbox mini fridge guys spoiler
this is where we might need the saw
you just don't want to take me to the
hospital
what's in here oh the drinks are in here
oh my god and a custom controller what
the heck is this
oh do you
even recognize me who is she
look at this little coasters oh shoot
this is cool oh my gosh there's so many
flavors oh
160 milligrams of natural caffeine this
looks like it's an original flavor
we've also got a lemon lime oh
a pineapple coconut super berry i think
this might be the one i'm gonna be into
and then wild orange you'll see that
controller i'll show you how control it
check this out let's get these started
cooling
in our big fridge
never gets old except for when i need
space in my garage
then i question my choices but all right
we gotta get this out of here we gotta
get we gotta get you out
oh yeah here it is
this is so freaking cute
you saw nothing oh oh it's so
small look how tiny this is
what am i even gonna put here some
cheese sticks like some string cheese
let's put tiny fridge in big fridge big
fridge
tiny fridge
[Music]
it's a new party trick post pandemic
it's gonna be great hey come see my
fridge with the fridge inside the fridge
i should probably plug the actual baby
fridge in too do you know what this
is this is for the car i can take
my mini xbox fridge with me on the go
too bad i don't have a car
i have one but like i don't know where
it is okay i gotta take the fridge out
of the fridge
has anybody ever said that sentence
i need to take the fridge out of the
fridge
for everything and it's on
okay it doesn't make a noise but that's
okay this is what we can do
this is really cool i'll put a link in
the description if you guys want to
check out the new energy drink that
dwayne johnson just came out with
and microsoft xbox dwayne whoever
sent this to me thank you guys so much
you obviously know that i'm a huge xbox
fan so
it's gonna go to good use should i put
the fridge back in the fridge
do you think snoop will be putting his
fruit inside of his fridge
i'll ask him
you